hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to dark wood a game that
I've been following for quite a while
now it is actually something that I
supported when it was on Kickstarter and
I didn't even realize that it was out on
early access Steam
now this is a different horror game that
you're probably used to it involves a
top-down perspective and a randomly
generated free roaming world I don't
know too much about it because this is
the first time I've loaded up this game
and this loading screen is taking a long
time and I'm just trying to stall
blabber blabber blabber
maybe blabber to do oh god okay then I
guess we're ready even when I'm asleep I
can't stop seeing their faces whose
faces your friends and fellow that face
we keep in looking at me with trust I
don't think that expression was trust
like I could heal them save them from
spreading the plague
ah that prison seems to be missing a
rather significant part of his body like
I could stop the process which destroys
their lands rust their bodies in my hair
ah feat mace loudly I was where to start
the day there is no way out of here I am
stuck with that
it's actually the first thing that I
recorded today so way a horror in the
morning nothing wakes you up better with
their unending calling pleading cries
and muttered prayers hello oh that's
actually pretty cool bit more animation
than I was expecting okay so the idea
this game is you collect items in the
environment like most of these adventure
games and try to find a way out or try
to find a way to survive those are
usually the two objectives and I seem to
be drinking my sorrows away okay then
ooh this looks lovely okay I searched a
chair and found a camera that's logical
but uh whoa okey dokey that looks good
December 6 1985 somebody had two faces
possibly three that most people are
supposed to have only one kooky cages oh
good okay so I'm assuming that I'm some
sort of doctor guy ah that's lovely oh
good
comforting music good thing there's
still radio music going on I used to
store some stuff here but it jammed a
long time ago probably from all these
zombie barnacles growing around the
walls here trees
hello my bed I'm afraid to go to sleep
why because there's monsters and zombies
around
I know these notes by heart I don't want
to read them now oh here we go
alcohol perfect exactly what I needed
would perfect exactly what matchsticks
perfect rags okay and key yeah could go
hello key found front door key good that
way I'll be able to God into the world
and do something barricaded whoa
dismantling this now would be suicide
awesome so I can just I can barricade my
own things in this world of nightmares
that's actually really cool not gonna
lie wondering Lu oh what is that oh oh
is that a dead body
Oh's out of that child okay locked I
think I left my key in the Wardrobe if
the cursor has a plus icon lines Mac to
do it
you can hold LM B to open the selected
objects action menu oh cool so I can
barricade things if I need to oh what's
that oh oh that's a dog okay some uh my
dog I don't think he's good whoa I
should end his suffering I'd be
responsible of me pelada I just met him
okay oh that's a wooden doll a large
humanoid doll with a cutout face that
somehow even creepier than what I was
doing before okay can I run yes I can
run okay so that's the entrance to the
barricaded window this looks like it
goes up in wait oh can I go through oh I
don't want to I don't want to oh don't
wanna I can't see what I was going to
saw some wigglies in the woods wind blew
woods they woke well I found some rope
that would be oh he's so sad Oh what do
I do
how do I end just suffering wood is
there an axe or something maybe oh I
feel bad was that a cellar over the
barricaded window either I am ejecting
beams of light out of my eyeballs or I
have some sort of head Mantid Mantid had
me onto the flashlight going on here so
okay so space to jump over obstacles
like fences and windows so here we go
into the game cow god I'm actually
really excited about this I was like you
know the typical in the horror
experience that you usually see is oh
that is an axe oh no oh no do I have to
I have to do that oh is that a
durability formidable weapon dull blade
lighter I don't understand how an axe
would be okay
so I swing it okay oh oh there we go I
got to hold it down oh but I don't wanna
can I just chop some woods Oh err kid
what in the world is this stuff there's
a lot of stuff in this world that I
don't exactly know but at least that
stacks up so I'm assuming I gotta chop
this down yeah that didn't do nothing
jump over it what do I do
wait hold right mouse button to aim and
then left bow oh I see
okay I was letting go the right mouse
button oh no oh I have to go back and oh
it would be merciful oh why did I leave
my dog outside if I was in an apocalypse
that dog would be inside I wouldn't even
care if he poop everywhere I wouldn't
even know I don't wanna Oh for your eyes
that's a horrible way to start off this
game I mean I guess it is dark oh that's
a horrible oh my god why why did you
make me do that okay let's just move on
there's a cow so decompose halfway into
the ground oh that's a good sound a
fully-loaded attack deals more damage
and staggers enemies so if I just walk
around with my axe over my head I should
be generally pretty good
all right come on you bastards okay come
on
who wants some there's no escape from
these woods only the rats can squeeze
themselves between the trees what does
that even mean how the trees grown aah
shut up you Birds dad here okay so I'm
using everything except humans oh maybe
I was supposed to find like a medkit and
heal my doggie oh did I do horrible
thing
oh no I'm like second-guess myself this
whole game these parts of the woods are
dark and you've crafted torch my eyeball
beams of light can't go oh there's a
crafting oh my goodness that's cool
that's really oh no my booze I'm gonna
need to use my booze okay wait what is
why I read towards what does that do
okay so put that on my taskbar get my
torch out okay now that beams of light
eyes brilliant baby blue eyes are
amplified by this orange torch okay
it's oddly disconcerting like I've said
before some of the scariest games are
really immersive experiences that I
played have been the RPG horror games
I'm so glad I gotta have to put
everything away before going out there
but they've been the RPG horror games
that I played in the past I don't know
how far I'm gonna get into this game
right now but I'm very very intrigued
okay so here's about old that is not
happy well that's not a happy sight what
is that oh what is that oh that's moving
okay all right then what the hell are
you Oh
corpse in a few days it will be
completely absorbed what do you mean by
that you want to give me some more
information about your genius notes over
here how you managed to survive
reminds me of the game lone survivor
that I played really really interesting
story god that was messed up stuff going
on
rags sir way to just quickly I don't
know if there's anything besides us me
clicking and dragging this okay sorry
okay really do like the ambience and
sounds I'm just exploring this dark
world that's why I was so excited about
I mean I've seen a lot of top-down
horror games but they're usually the
running gun rooty tooty aim and shoot ii
type of games where you're just
sprinting through his Ami's blowing them
up it's really cool to see a kind of
immersive experience that's just about
oh hello I'm not I'm not gonna put you
out of your misery or Miami or I'm I oh
I think this one is still alive I'll
just check these I'll just take these
why do they have a value what is he'll a
cutscene
he's unconscious a little rat didn't
make it into his hole if he's got the
key he must know a door is what is all
this not a good idea
only pests like him know how to get out
of these woods
of course he won't willingly tell me
anything one but this however what Oh
doesn't really matter what the hell did
I just do what huh wait a minute what
what did I just do an entry to a small
cellar probably for storing food Wyatt
I'm hurt I could use these rags to craft
a bandage and heal myself okay that is
cool
oh it's so cool I'm playing us guys just
kidnapped and injected with a thing oh
my goodness girls going on here I can
only dismantle barricades which I have
created cuz they'd just be too complex
okay so I can uh KITT pick the lock here
unlock and go down in the trapdoor
that's what Oh okay those are items I
can get I thought that was crafting menu
again okay okay then we got a flashlight
now I got a shovel and I can need to use
this how do I use that
ah there we go just hold down the clicky
and that should do it
okay that's slowly slowly regenerating
my health okay so I just doesn't realize
now my my FaceCam will be on the other
side of the game so that's why that
makes sense to the thing that you can't
see anyway sorry okay don't anyway now I
need to find a way to get out of here so
I'm assuming I need to use a shovel to
finish the barricade down yes
come on
little rat venison echoey creepy crap
going on there oh I have an energy bar
too so I need to make sure I could serve
that it'll be very dangerous of irena
item is no longer usable I need to
repair it okay but I can open it I don't
think I have anything hello hi there
sorry I'm in the crazy doctors health
well those weren't those were oh I see
sorry well the hell is happening okay
alright then I'm in the crazy doctors
house haha oh didn't realize that I was
actually the crazy one here okay
alrighty then this is good I like this
Oh with the dork Oh I better not leave
the house at night it's safer in here
what you mean it's safer in here there's
an insane Oh doctor trying to kill you
okay so that's barricaded up okay do you
even understand how you got here man you
don't even know do you
ah pit lockpick okay don't have who's
there who's there
please let me out what okay I got to
find another wire to be able to do the
thing okay so I just need to find a wire
so I gotta search somewhere in here get
a Y aha here we go Nold radio god
there's no power in this house I do not
understand a damn thing that is
happening right now
i certs await search plus drag it oh I
can drag it out of the way got it got
guy yes excellent god I got I got it
okay how many look to win it I mean it's
win this baby alright who's in here
generator switch on okay the generator
is turned off yeah I can hear a faint
metallic sound of an engine turn on has
I reached my hand towards the positive I
suddenly hear a voice gasoline gasoline
why what are you like a miserable
okay so the generator was talking to me
that's normal the figure on the bed is
wearing a worn coat and weathered hat
his eyes are fixed on the hilt of a
scalpel stuck in his forehead was that
Smee I don't recognize his face but I
know he is that's me I don't even
understand what the hell is going on
what in the world this is incredible oh
yes take time to search while something
sneaks up behind me oh good gasoline
lockpick good wood I got nails and
barricades something up a dog tag no
1918 wait a minute Oh dog tag is in army
dog I thought it was the dog that a hug
Hey nevermind I'm normal everybody shut
up I'm just I'm still like totally
confused and that's awesome okay so I
gotta equip the gasoline maybe that
there it's not quite full okay wait a
minute
put that prime it and then refill it got
it got it
refill refill refill refill refill okay
come on refill it Rick come on
I'm guessing this so I don't have to use
all of it to be able to do the thing
that I need so that's good there I'll
put that back there
oh my goodness well that's nice it's
really nice all I got to quickly do this
stuff that I need to do okay loud
squeaky noises turn that off don't
conserve power here what is this five
nights at Freddy's yeah use lockpick
unlocked okay who's in there help who
I cannot see cannot sit who's there what
the hell conclusive
I don't wanna oh my god Jesus no that
was a bad idea
oh my goodness
was a hell oh my god
whoa uh got a shovel no I need to repair
the shovel hi repair a shovel Mike with
nails you got you're gonna get it you
get a nail plank to the face brick get
it no beat your face in I'm gonna do to
you ah no no yeah oh yeah she's blood on
my screen come on go on you want fight
prayer right path no no no no no get out
of here that's right that's right
don't mess with me is that the doctor
did I just kill the doctor
or maybe the doctors waiting for me what
the hell is wrong with the doctor I
don't even understand well that's not
good sounds that's exactly the bad
sounds
can you hear what I can hear that yes I
can are you dead with you nothing coming
in Oh something is coming in Oh
something is getting in here okay I need
to barricade myself in someplace safe
Rison rise and shine double hello wolf
man what happened what happened I don't
even understand you are literally a wolf
man I could feel your stench from afar
you should be thankful I don't have an
appetite for caucuses ah he eyes his
face under a hood he can feel the smell
of wet ground and fur looks like he was
shot two and got a Kalashnikov over
there I came after your reek to inform
you about something but looking at your
face someone has already done just that
these woods are full of little trinkets
treasures if you find anything valuable
I'll gladly have a look at it maybe even
give you something in exchange my
hideout is close by to the south of here
remember this because the likes of you
always crawl back to me okay
oh I almost forgot a little welcome
breathand with this unusual bucket you
will be able to drink our local
crystal-clear water straight from the
well you'll see when the night comes you
won't be able to live without it okay
then I have a dog tag that I received
from a nightmare fever dream is that
good enough for you oh what a beautiful
thing this is meat I know who it
belonged to
wolf giggles as he looks at the dog dag
you'd like to now - huh it's funny that
someone would like to speak so much
won't ever say a word
someone who would like to I'll give you
a piece of advice almost for free if you
want to know more about where this thing
came from find the woman who stinks of
chickens a your Viner in the cottage not
very far to the south east of here wolf
makes a step in my direction you vine
anything with wild from her do remember
that I like information it would be wise
to live in good terms with me come
red-meat so he's a Russian wolf he's
Russian wolf
maybe the dog dad belong to him for all
I know um predict some poisonous gas
that sounds good
oh man the doctor had all sorts of good
stuff what do you mean he got had a key
and everything I don't have anything I
have an odd mushroom and a bucket Wow
I'm doing great over here
okay gossip taking stroll through the
woods after dusk means sudden death meat
better find some walls hide behind
before nightfall and pray for the
morning light okay then god this game is
much more involved than I thought
access a journal my present Jay that's
that there's really no way to get
between them black walls made from trees
and roots I don't know what to look for
here it's a bloody trap I feel the walls
getting closer and closer there's no
place for a human being
no it's dog tag people location keys
plus items I got nothing and no skills
nothing worth a damn in here so I need
to quickly find a way to barricade up my
stuff
God how do I even save this game they're
even away I have nothing okay I have
absolutely nothing but I managed to find
a dog tag somehow okay so he said his
base with to the south there's a locker
up there then I'm gonna check real quick
I'm gonna try to save there's a lot more
to this game than I thought might
actually play it a few times okay where
am i how do i how am I even do I always
end up do nothing in here there's not a
damn thing in here is there where to
save or something not that I can see I'm
really hoping that it autosave because I
wanted I want to play this again I'm all
out of time for this episode but I want
to play this again this is awesome this
is really cool okay all right all right
so I'm gonna ways with a hammer little
hammer together here that's not cooking
what is breaking bad what am i cooking
what's kind of super meth in that giant
needle let's cook up some mushrooms baby
oh yes oh yes oh I need all I need to
fill a dose I'm gonna fill that dose
before I go I wanna oh that is so
interesting
I can't quit yet I can't quit there's so
much more stuff that I need to see here
hello
hello somebody out here is that weirdo
doctor that oh that was me breathing
okay I thought I heard something
hello what are you ah here we go good
stuff good stuff good stuff a bear trap
for bears and other things
no mastic I got no weapon so I'd be
pretty much stuck so can this doctor
wasn't even the main character of this
thing he's a guy that sent me out made
me go on some wacky crazy drug trip with
whatever he injected me with and I'm
looking to inject myself with more stuff
why and then he's just gonna follow me
to the point where I lead him out of 100
underground entrance I'm so going there
so the wolfy hideout to the south so
okay so I need to not sprint because
that actually uses some stuff there's a
dusty old locker get bear trap another
bear okay can't stack them what is that
junk Matt sticks wait whoa small caliber
magazine when did that get there okay
that okay so cool cool cool cool that
means that during the night then I can
actually sneak stuff in ah I love this
I'm freaking out because it's so cool I
got a lot of bear traps here 9-volt
battery go - go - good good good good
gonna get a key to get to give you oh
man oh yes most of us are perfect
got it how many mushrooms how many
mushrooms that's one I need more with
more mushrooms man I need two more
because they each give 30 come on give
me another mushroom I want to dose
myself up so badly we need to cook
whatever my name is I don't even know my
name okay I found a broken tractor
there's a location that I put on my map
ah bad big battery pellets for a gun and
gasoline but I already have gasoline
probably just gonna dump this junk I
know I'll probably find more junk down
the road but I just want to make sure
that I have what I need to go forward
okay mushrooms mushrooms where are you
cluster mushrooms logs nails wood I need
wood I got too much crap oh I guess I
can put them on my main bar I didn't
even think about that okay okay okay
okay
mushrooms yes I'm gonna do myself up so
good God
it goddess don't even know how to save
whatever well I don't have my axe
anymore my poor dog my mind is going a
million miles an hour because oh okay
junk ah Molotov that sounds important
I guess I'll dump the junk again the
junk isn't worth much and I only can get
a max of ten so I don't suppose that
it's necessary right now but then again
I don't know what there is here this
game I want to play more episodes of
this but I can't say that I will be
playing it forever and ever and ever
it looks like a generator over there so
I might be able to fill that up I might
just do a few episodes of this because
this is really really cool here can I
jump through that one yes I can
let's cook a wolf man's gone apparently
oh yes yes
fill me up I have a dose Oh what do I
got see better sight underneath objects
like trees animals are less aggressive
towards you more space on your hotbar
ooh how does that even make sense how
can I checked myself and make my pockets
bigger oh I can make other things bigger
if I inject myself you know what I mean
but I don't know about that Oh more my
bigger pockets on bigger stuff yes
please okay well those well alright then
that was a little oh there's more
anticlimactic than I'd hoped but either
way I guess that's it for now okay so
this game let me pause it so make sure
nothing happens crazy cool I'm gonna
play another episode of this this is
amazingly cool I want to find out more
about dark wood and I'm so interested so
if you got comments down in the
description below I'm actually gonna
play right now but please tell me if
there's stuff that I'm missing if
there's really cool stuff this game is
really cool it's a little pricey on
Steam at 15 bucks but if there's more to
this game than I think there is I
thought it was just gonna be a one-off
but idly enough there's a lot of stuff
to this game and I want to find out more
so I'm gonna I'm gonna explore a bit
more I'm gonna find out more about it
and hopefully I'll get back to you guys
soon I just don't want to lose my save
if I can help it
so either way thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
give you gave up cave games that I've
played and as always I will see you in
the next video
but no go no go it
gosh